all right good afternoon thanks for
coming out to learn a little bit about
typescript I think this will be a fun
topic it's something I certainly have
found fascinating as I have had a chance
to use it and explore it and preparing
to teach it so hopefully you'll learn
something here a little bit or learn a
few additional techniques that you can
use in your typescript to communicate
your intent more clearly one of the
interesting things about all programming
languages is that they are all just
communication tools typically the
communication is between the developer
and the compiler but there's also a very
important part of the communication that
is between one developer and the rest of
the developers or between part of the
team and other part of the team or the
ever-popular
myself as I'm writing the code today and
myself as I'm trying to maintain this
code six months from now
because future-self is pretty angry at
my current self on a pretty regular
basis my wife and I have been here all
week we are from Indiana and it's been a
lot of fun getting to spend some time in
Australia one of the things that we've
enjoyed are those subtle language
differences between the American English
dialect in the Australian English
dialect one of them that caught my eye
the other day and we actually got a
picture of it is these signs on the
escalators that say way up and that's
interesting to us because in the United
States if you would have a similar
marking it would probably simply say up
you know I don't know where that why
that's funny or different to me the same
thing with way out or way down those are
not ever things you would see on signs
in the United States
but honestly this is more descriptive
and more accurate if we were in the
States you would probably just say which
is true but that doesn't really tell you
too much about it the fact that we can
here just say way up actually tells you
little bit more and that's very similar
to the relationship between JavaScript
and typescript both languages have the
same capabilities is just that
typescript can be more descriptive of
what's going on and the fact that
typescript actually compiles down to
JavaScript should be a pretty good
indication that there's not a lot of
additional functionality you get it's
just it's really about how much
information are you communicating in
your code so just to level set before we
get into the presentation this is not
going to be an intro to typescript talk
I'm going to assume that you guys have
some experience with typescript because
I want to move on to some of the things
that I find a little more entertaining
and so I'm not going to go into some of
the fundamentals of typescript like how
you add types to variables or parameters
or how you create classes how you type
definition files or configuring the
build and all those things so if you
want more information on that I'm sure
you can find it but you won't find it in
here this hour so I'm curious this show
of hands how many of you are currently
using typescript
for some of your work okay that's
fantastic
so I think it's safe to say that you
guys don't need this information I'm not
going to try and cover it you will
obviously see some examples of this a
lot of these things are the things that
make typescript so incredibly powerful
and so incredibly useful on larger
projects but different topic for a
different day so one of the key features
of typescript is the type system and
they're tricky they'd hit it right in
the first four characters of the
language name and so we're gonna do a
real quick review on datatypes which I
know is kind of like a
intro to computer science type of topic
but we're gonna buzz through it real
quick just so that we have that all the
same terminology so just as a refresher
a data type defines the collection of
data values in a predefined set of
operations on those values so we're
talking about some kind of object and
what it can know and what I can do if we
were going to draw this up on a
whiteboard if we're just gonna diagram
out what it would be we would usually
some use some kind of pseudo UML that
looks kind of like this where we'd have
some kind of type name we would have the
data and the operations or as we
sometimes will say the type and its
state and its behavior and we have a
type then the sub or the members of the
type can also have types on them so we
can have a type and then the members
also have you know you know get of type
A and type B there could be numbers and
strings and whatever else so to have a
slightly more concrete example of a data
type we could have a type that
represents a person and it might have
state to represent the first name and
the last name those would probably
represent it as strings and there might
be some kind of behavior here to get the
greeting for that person that is a
function that also returns a string so
that being said I mean this is kind of
like the classic definition of data
types that's fairly universal across all
programming languages and so now we'll
dive into a little bit more about
specifically what typescript can do one
of the really useful things that
typescript adds / JavaScript is the use
of generics now if you're familiar with
c-sharp this implementation will
probably look fairly familiar to you how
many of you guys have some background as
a c-sharp developer okay it's pretty
common for typescript developers and as
you probably know type
script was developed by Andrews House
Berg who is also the chief architect on
c-sharp and so a lot of the decisions he
made with C Sharpie repeated with
typescript so it looks very similar
again as a quick refresher generics just
mean that we can have a parameter a type
parameter that we pass to another type
so now I can have a data type that's
going to accept a type parameter so now
I can determine the data type of one of
the members or one of the functions at a
later time where we see this most
commonly is with collections
so while JavaScript only has an array
type typescript can have an array of T
if we were going to have a typescript
implementation of the eight Queens
problem we would need a collection of
Queens have you guys are familiar with
eight Queens problem okay
eight Queens problem and it's at least
where I come from it's a very common
programming language kata or you know
something a real simple problem that you
solve over and over again but the idea
is that on a chess board you could in
theory take eight Queens and place them
all on the chess board so that none of
them can attack one another and so if
we're going to do that we could have a
collection of Queens or in this case an
array of queen and then we could have
logic that loops over each one of those
Queens now in JavaScript we could have
this same functionality and we could put
eight of these objects into a collection
it just wouldn't be type safe so what
does that mean for us it means that in
theory we could have a teammate or a
future version of ourselves that is
working on the code and we put something
into that collection that is not
the type who were expecting so this is
seems like it should be obvious but a
lot of times this can really save us a
lot of hassle one of the places where my
team in particular has seen the benefits
of generics is actually using some of
the spa frameworks where there's some
objects that might be queen or in some
that might be an observable of queen or
you knockout has like its own data
binding wrapper around some of the data
types and so there can be these subtle
programming errors where I think I'm
working with a queen but I actually have
an observable queen if I'm using
typescript and typescript is going to
force me to put the right type of
objects into the collection I have some
additional assurance that I'm not going
to pull something out of the array and
get the wrong thing now one of the
things that's important to remember
about typescript is that all of our good
type safety actually goes away when we
compile down to JavaScript so here's
that same code rendered in JavaScript as
a part of our build system whatever
we're doing we're gonna transpiler type
scripts it becomes JavaScript you can
see that same collection exists here on
this array and it's just now it's just
an array it's not an array of Queen just
an array and so all that type safety
that we get from typescript
exists when we're writing the code not
necessarily not necessarily when we're
running the code so that's generics
another fairly quick refresher on how
inheritance works when we have one data
type we can have another type that
inherits from it so I can have a parent
type that defines its behavior in state
and I can have a child type that adds or
modifies the behavior and
and we would say that these types have
an is a relationship so if the concrete
example here is the child type is a
person in the they're the yeah the base
type is person in the child type is
programmer we could say that a
programmer is a person and in typescript
we can implement this fairly simply when
I define a class I can just say that my
child class extends person this is one
of the places where typescript is
slightly different than c-sharp
where now I'm going to use an extends
keyword instead of the colon that we
would use in c-sharp and when we build
out these relationships a lot of times
the simple versions of these
relationships make a lot of sense but
they can start to get messy especially
when you start to have three or four or
seventy classes inherited from one
another and it is a relationship start
to get muddy and that means that our
types aren't exactly what we want
so in general why did that circle stay
there
no strain there good what we prefer to
do is have composition over inheritance
so we can build our data types up
through multiple classes not necessarily
inheriting from one another that tends
to work out better in fact you could
argue that the classic design patterns
book often known as the Gang of Four
book is just a long explanation of how
we can leverage composition over
inheritance and typescript has some
really interesting ways to use
composition that a lot of the other
languages don't have so the first one
that I want to talk about is
intersection types and this is the first
feature that we're going to talk about
today that is much more specific to
typescript and not so much a feature of
other languages with intersection types
we can basically take two types and add
them together so let's say we're working
on a piece of software that manages our
software team and handle some invoicing
we could very conceivably have one class
for programmer and another class for
billable resource and we could have a
need to have an object that is both a
programmer and a billable resource but
we don't necessarily want to say that
all programmers are billable resources
and we don't necessarily want to say
that all billable resources are
programmers because we can think of
exceptions to both of those so what I
can do in typescript is I can create a
new type that is like these two things
mashed together and as long as we're
just dealing with the data that's
actually pretty simple to do so in this
case I'm going to have an interface that
defines a programmer employee and it's
got fields for first name last name in
favorite language and I've got another
interface for
or billable resource that just defines
its hourly rate but where the real magic
happens is here what I'm going to define
a billable programmer and I'm just going
to say that the billable programmer is
of type programmer employee and billable
resource and all I had to do is take the
two type names and use the ampersand
right there to kind of join them
together and on the fly I have created a
new type that it represents both of
those together and so you can see that
now in this new object I can assign a
first name a last name a favorite
language in an hourly rate and then I
can also take my billable programmer
language or billable programmer object
and call into its first name and it's
hourly rate so that works out pretty
well now I have an object that
represents the the intersection of those
two things I can use it however I need
it gets a little more interesting if I
have classes where there's some
additional functionality so in in this
version of the example I now have a
class programmer and it's got a method
get greeting and the billable resource
class has a method get invoice amount
and it's not as easy as simply assigning
those two things together now I actually
need a way to combine those methods well
what I can do is I can write a custom
function to take all of the functions
from one object and put them into
another this is a technique that is very
common
in the Ruby community it's called
mix-ins this is not something that's
nearly as common to see sharp developers
but typescript supports mix-ins and so
what I've got here is a function that's
going to take two types and like we
talked about earlier it's got these
generic type parameters first and second
and it is going to return an object that
is a first and second or the
intersection of first and second and it
will basically loop through all the
properties on the first one and add them
to the new object and it'll loop through
all of the properties of the second
object and add them to the new object
and then it's just going to return the
result which takes in all the properties
and methods from either object now this
implementation is slightly naive if both
classes that got passed in and let's say
they both had a method with the same
name in this case that would just get
stepped on and whichever one was came in
last would win but this this certainly
would work so if we were going to use
this I could define a programmer object
in this case Don the one the programmers
named Don Syme which for the record I
put this code example before I knew he
was gonna be here this week so I know
it's pretty easy
it's pretty fun for me to get to walk
around and have one of my programmer
heroes here so that's cool I
unfortunately won't get to see a session
tomorrow because we have to travel back
that makes me sad but anyway back to
this we've got this object
programmer I've got I could also just
define my billable resource they're on
line five I could call get greeting on
my program where object on line ten I
could call get invoice amount on my
billable resource but down here on line
fourteen what I'm calling extend I'm
going to pass in my new programmer
object with the billable resource
prototype those mix-ins will get added
to the new object and now I could call
get greeting or get invoice amount on
that object one of the things that's
kind of cool about this is the
intellisense on this is really good
let's pop over to the code so you can
see it
let's see
which by the way if you're keeping score
at home I'm using TS jest for all these
code samples it's just a really
convenient way for me to write some some
typescript and execute it without having
to be concerned with building out a
whole website so here's my object dawn
which I don't know if you can how what
you can see that but you can see my
intellisense in Visual Studio code is
representing this type as the
intersection type you know it's putting
that ampersand right on there and you
know the intellisense is well aware that
if I just have one of these dawn objects
I should be able to call into any of the
methods on either of the objects so the
tooling around the intersection types
works really well and that really is one
of the reasons why typescript does some
of the things that does is to enable
tools like Visual Studio code to help
you out one of the things that a lot of
people don't know is that the way Visual
Studio code gives JavaScript developers
such good
intellisense help and other tooling help
is that Visual Studio code treats all
JavaScript as typescript
so the way Visual Studio code does the
intellisense for javascript is it just
takes the JavaScript and runs it to the
typescript compiler and so it should not
be surprising when we look at the
tooling for a typescript and it's
phenomenal
alright so that was intersection types
the next thing that I want to introduce
you to is Union types Union type a Union
type is a type where we're going to say
that we have an object and it is going
to be either type A or type B or type C
or type D depending on your doing and so
where intersection types is kind of like
the logical and of two types the Union
type is the logical or of two type
definitions and when we have a Union
type objects that are defined as these
Union types can specifically only call
the functionality that is common to both
but we have a way to kind of tease out
the other functionality so let's look at
how we might use this a little bit in
this example we still have a class
called programmer we have another class
called tester and we have a third class
called product owner and let's imagine
that we have a scenario where we are
assigning tasks in our sprint to one of
these individuals but because the
product owner doesn't really get tasks
assigned to him or her we are going to
just limit the assignment to programmers
or testers so what I could do is I could
have code that looks like this where the
assignment takes a programmer or a
tester and then I can assign the task to
that person the nice thing here is that
I would actually get a compiler error if
I try to pass in a
product owner but as I mentioned before
when you're dealing with an object that
is assigned the Union type you can't
necessarily call the methods on one of
the specific types in this case get name
is a method on both programmer and
tester so I can call that but get
favorite language is only a method on
the programmer and so I can't call that
that would actually be a compiler error
so when I've got one of these Union
types
I could I could substitute a programmer
or a tester for that so I declare a
programmer on line 16 and I can on line
20 assign the task to the programmer or
really assign the programmer to the task
on line 23 I could assign the tester to
the task and I don't have it here but on
line 23 if I create a new product owner
and try and pass him in to the task it
will not work let's pop over and look at
that real quick
so here's the code I'm trying to assign
a new product owner but I'm getting a
compiler error and again the tooltip is
pretty useful
it says argument of type product owner
is not assignable to parameter of type
programmer or tester and so we can know
right away that that we've done
something wrong here now just like we
saw with generics the type safety that
we get here does go away at compile time
and so if we found some really
horrendous JavaScript workaround we
could in if we could get it into the
JavaScript assign our product owner into
the task but at least at compile time we
have that type safety and again this is
kind of the big theme of this whole talk
is that typescript gives you ways to
help you communicate what you're trying
to do to your teammates not necessarily
get additional functionality at runtime
the fact that I have specifically made
the parameter to the assign method the
union of programmer or tester is really
for future developers not so much for
runtime safety
now we're union types our most commonly
used is to represent potential heir
cases and this is a pattern that is very
common if you come from a functional
programming background developers that
work a lot in elixir or Scala or F sharp
are very familiar to this pattern but
developers that have come from more of a
c-sharp or Java background often are
unfamiliar with this pattern so let's
imagine a new scenario where we have
some code that is working with these
programmer objects and in fact it's
storing them in the database and we need
to be able to retrieve some data from
the database we want to look up a
programmer by name return the result and
as you all know looking things up in the
database never goes wrong there's no way
I can ever have any exceptions so we
don't have to worry about it right cuz
that is me okay you guys are probably
the really good programmers I have found
a lot of ways to make this go wrong in
my career so for bad programmers like me
we need this kind of stuff so what I
want to be able to do is I want to
define a class programmer that has the
actual information that I I want and I
want to have another class called lookup
failed and in my code that looks up the
data in the database I am going to
return a programmer lookup result which
a programmer lookup result is basically
just a type alias for the Union type of
programmer or look I've failed so this
is something else that I'm just gonna
talk about real quick
oops that was not what I wanted Oh
jumping ahead
so this code here on line 16 where we're
going to just define a type and set it
equal to two other types that's called a
type alias this is not something that's
specific to union types you could do the
same thing with intersection types it's
just a convenient way to represent what
the Union type is here in my opinion
having an alias on the Union type makes
it even more explicit in the code what
you're trying to do it's just one more
communication mechanism you have to the
other teammates so in a real version of
this code our programmer repository
would have a named method called get by
name they would actually connect to a
database and do the sequel thing that it
was gonna do in this very simple version
it is going to look up a or it's going
to return a new error message every time
so it's just going to return a new
lookup failed but what we can do because
it's the Union type we can either return
the programmer if everything went well
or we can return the error message this
is a contrast to how these type of
scenarios are normally handled where the
return type would always be programmer
and if something goes wrong we'd throw
an exception but when we return the
Union of the object in the failure the
code that calls that like it would here
on line 22 is going to get back the
result the result is going to be that
Union type and instead of having to
catch an exception what I do is inspect
the result and so I can say if result is
an instance of programmer than I do you
know whatever the programmer thing is
you know if the result is a lookup
failed that I'm going to have my failure
case
by the way this is called a type guard
what you're seeing here on lines 24 and
26 the type guard is the code that looks
at the actual type inside of the Union
type and you could actually have
additional cases if the Union type
supported that but this allows us to
figure out which one of the Union type
we actually have one of the things that
is worth noting again is that the
intellisense on this is really good it's
actually kind of fun let's look at the
example of that yeah this is the one
that I want nope that was not the one
that I wanted
so if I look at the type of result here
we know it's a programmer lookup result
and if I try to say result dot get
favorite language I should get a
compiler error that says get favorite
favorite language does not exist on type
programmer look-up result it actually
gives me an alternative solution which
says get favorite language does not
exist on lookup failed because remember
when you have Union types if there are
functions that are common to all of the
types I could call those and so I can
either resolve this issue by actually
only doing something that exists on
program or lookup result or I could
change lookup failed to support get
favorite language which is obviously not
what I want to do but it is worth noting
that I don't have to cast the result I
just have to have this type guard so the
exact same code that is a compiler error
here is absolutely fine inside of that
type guard so once I've gone through
that type guard the compiler is smart
enough to know that result actually is
an instance of programmer and those
methods are fair game so
any questions so far yes the the union
types so my experience has been that
developers that start handling errors
with the union types really start to
enjoy that one of the things that's nice
about this is that once I've got this
code because of the way that
intellisense works in the compiler error
you are forced to handle that error so I
couldn't call get favorite language
until I have the type guard once I have
the type guard then like oh yeah I need
to handle the air as well whereas within
if an exception is thrown there's an
always a chance that you just have an
unhandled exception error I'm sure you
guys are all really good developers and
you'd never have unhandled exceptions in
your code me I need the the warm hug of
a compiler that you know forces me to
deal with these things so there is some
there's some niceties about kind of
being forced into the pit of success and
having to deal with those air cases now
the downside of that is that with
exceptions I could in theory allow the
air to bubble up a couple levels and
catch it at a higher level and so there
is some additional flexibility you get
by using you know throwing an error
instead of returning a union type so you
know it's not that one is right and one
is wrong it's there's trade-offs my
experience has been that Union types
tend to lead towards cleaner solutions
but feel free to decide for yourself I
actually have a whole blog post exactly
on that topic because
this is not the first time this question
has come up my blog will be linked at
the end but if you go to Humble tool
Smith comm I have a whole blog post that
actually builds out that this example
with both returning Union type in thrown
exception actually I've got that code on
my machine if you want to look at it
later too
yeah question back here what do you mean
can it be used in a ternary operator I
don't know should we try it
you guys are like is and try it and
what's the worst could happen Erica look
like a [ __ ] that's that's fine
so what you you want to say fav Lang
equals result instance of
what is the that's right
let's get rid of that yeah that seems to
be working it knows that favorite
language is a string
yeah it's picking it up yeah it knows
that result is a programmer by the time
we get past that ternary
I knows it's a look I've failed so
that's actually pretty cool just knows
exactly how I scripted that out thanks
man
I tell you what you find me afterwards
and we'll try it because now I'm really
curious to see what
alright that'll be an exercise for later
any other questions before I move on
yeah so I know I I should probably
change that slide because I make it look
like a Venn diagram it's not really a
Venn diagram and I apologize the visual
is correct the terminology is the it's
different than the Venn diagram
terminology so I don't know does that
answer your question
it's the terminology makes sense other
than the fact that it's different than
what a Venn diagram does yeah question
the back
so if you throw out are you saying if
what happens if we have a function that
returns a union type that could be the
air or throw an exception that could be
an error I mean that at that point the
exception if you throw the throw the
exception it's gonna bubble out over the
type guard so you could certainly have
an unhandled exception that way that
feels like a code smell if you were both
throwing exceptions and returning errors
in the Union type and I'm sure there are
reasons why you might do that but if you
were trying to mix those two paradigms I
think you would have to step back and
and take a little bit more about your
design good question though
other questions
all right
so one of the other really fun features
in typescript is something called string
literals and at first glance they're not
as thrilling is I am describing them as
but what I can do is I can create a type
alias and create what kind of looks like
a union of a bunch of strings but what I
can do is I can constrain objects of
type grade to be one of these five
strings so when I do this I can now have
a method enter grade and takes my name
and when I pass in a B that is
completely legit but if I try and pass
in an e which is also a string I get a
compiler error because E is not in the
the string literal defined of just ABCD
and F so one of the things that often
comes up when I'm explaining this
feature to people is that it looks an
awful lot like enumerations which it
does but one of the things about
enumerations is that under the hood all
enumerations are stored as numbers and
so while I would then have some kind of
numeric representation of ABCD and F
that would be different than actually
working with the string so in this case
I could have a string coming in from
various sources and I can verify the
actual string also I can I can call
these string methods on on the type and
so actually having a string that's
combined down to a finite set of strings
can be very useful one of the reasons
this becomes a really big deal in
typescript is that a lot of typescript
is doing some
kind of Dom manipulation meaning that we
have a lot of strings that mean very
specific things we might want to have a
method that is adding elements to the
Dom but we only want it to work with
divs and a tags and P tags and so we
could define a string literal that you
know is just the the union of those
three elements now we actually would get
good compiler time checking that the
string that passed in was one of the
elements that we expected so string
literals one of those features is kind
of it's kind of sneaky and how useful it
is usually once people start using them
like is there's actually a lot of
applications for that any questions on
string literals before we move on yeah
so
are you saying like you want to be able
to define like a string literal that
works with uppercase a and lowercase a I
mean you could manually do it but I
don't think there's a way to I don't
think you can like define a type that is
a case-insensitive string literal so and
also to answer your other question I
don't know of a way to you know
enumerate the list there might be not
sure it's also worth noting that we have
numeric literals as well these start to
get really close to enumerations you
know I could have a dice roll that is
just one two three four or five or six
but again not this one isn't as
interesting because enumerations do a
lot of the same thing although one of
the nice things about numeric literals
is that I could use floating-point
numbers so if I just wanted to have a
numeric literal that could only be three
point one four two point seven one I
could define that oh and it won't show
me the type here because I'm never
actually doing anything with it
I still still mad at me
yeah so you can see here that type 0 is
not assignable to type special numbers
so having I in my use cases the numeric
literals aren't something I don't think
I've ever used in production code string
literals tend to be something that you
get to use quite a bit good question
though
all right so kind of to wrap up to kind
of put a bow in this whole thing
programming languages like spoken
languages our communication mechanisms
one of the things I hope you have
learned today is there are some new
vocabulary that you've picked up that
you can use that will help you express
what it is that your code is trying to
do one of the things that I do want to
offer as a caveat is that in the same
way that if you put all these features
into like one function it would be
obnoxious it would be very similar to
meeting something with a really large
vocabulary that's really hard to
understand right don't go back to the
office on Monday and be like I'm gonna
use intersection types and union types
and string literals for everything
because that's not what you want but now
that you know that these things exist
you know I hope that you'll see
situations in the near future like oh
you know what I really want to be able
to do here is I want to be able to
communicate that this is going to be
Type A or type B and I can just using
you know type for that so hopefully
there's you picked up some new
vocabulary today and it'll help you
build better more reliable software in
the future so thanks for coming out
today like it said I've got a blog post
up on my blog humble tool Smith comm
that I there's a little bit deeper dive
into error handling
all the code we looked at today other
than the code that I literally typed in
the last ten minutes is up on github at
typescript beyond the basics all of
these slides again except for the ones
that a the one I added this morning are
up on SlideShare so if you wanted any of
this information down the road you can
get it there if you want to talk about
this more
feel free to ask I'll be hanging around
for a little bit afterwards the easiest
way to find me online is on twitter at
powder Eric I love to talk to you more
about this stuff or answer any questions
you might have so thanks for coming out
this has been fun and have a great rest
of the conference
[Applause]